uh there's there's an interesting story
i saw from zero hedge
zero hedge writes the portland riots
just
stopped why now i know some people like
zero hedge they're not considered to be
a credible outlet by newsguard
and just like really bad across the
board i don't ever really read zero
hedge or know much about them
but i can tell you that this article
is insinuating that around the same time
the prot
the riots were stopping in portland many
of these people
were not not these people many similar
people were seen
near these areas where brush fires were
starting
and it kind of plays into like are they
perhaps starting brush fires
there is a photo of people wearing
firefighter gear holding
up an antifa flag oh so it's all weird
but i think there's a much much easier
way to explain why this all stopped and
i think
it's because donald trump stopped it
that's a big part of it and that's very
simple
so here's here's what tyler durden
writes i guess like every article is by
tyler durden
how could this not be news guarded when
tyler durden's writing all your words
of course of course so uh this is what
they write since may 29th portland has
been the backdrop of more than 100
nights of anti-anarchist and black lives
matter inc
terroristic riots they set fires looted
and intimidated people by threatening to
burn them alive in their homes
but after the millions of dollars of
destruction criminality and thuggery is
stopped last week poof
why i certainly don't want to tempt
these thugs but it can't go without
saying
that portland's 100 plus days of rights
appeared to end
after wednesday september 9th that was
the last time the portland police bureau
warned about protesters with this tweet
saying southwest jefferson to southwest
salmon from southwest first to south
with
southwest broadway is closed to
pedestrians but open for vehicular
traffic
all people must leave the area to the
west now chapman and loundsdale squares
are now closed that's
just local jargon sure but that was what
they said
the usual live streamers decamped to
other riots and fires
by september 10th the overworked cops
from portland police bureau were offered
out
to assist other agencies suddenly
instead of being required to work the
riot lines they were free why on
september 7th
to the morning of the eighth the pacific
northwest experienced a major wind event
winds gusted through oregon and
washington at more than 60 miles per
hour
fires that had been allowed to crackle
along such as the beachy fire flared up
power lines were down the fires kicked
up
and then came the reports clackamas
county sheriff officials reported
that people had seen antifa protest
antifa protestor types
reportedly stashing gas cans looting and
looking ridiculously out of place
they were taking pictures and giving
locals grief force for trying to keep
them out of closed neighborhoods
locals wondered if there was a
connection between the fires
and the sightings of these folks blm was
seen there
the original blm the bureau of land
management not the group that borrowed
the acronym
now i want to point out there was one
guy who was
described by cairo 7 local news as being
a frequent
visitor of uh defund the police protests
this guy got arrested the police said he
was trying to set a fire that's the one
guy we have
there's been a bunch of other crazy
looking people and i feel like i have an
answer to why people thought that was
the case
why were they seeing these antifa types
that were out of place well it's because
these are the are
many of the crazies who antifa preys
upon
the organizers seek out these unwell
people give them a grievance and then
rally them to go
cause destruction because idle hands the
devil's playground
these people have nothing to do so when
these people have nothing to do and the
organizers are are gone
what do they do they run amok i don't
think these people starting fires are
far leftists for the most part i don't
think they're intentionally
like it's a antifa conspiracy i think
the accus the insinuations through this
are leading in the wrong direction they
don't actually say
that antifa was causing this however
they go on
catherine herridge mentions this dhs
leaked uh
email that says this is written written
on day 60 of the portland riots that
antifa is organized
not opportunistic they know what they're
doing so then
this is how zero hatch ends they're
organized share the same tactics and
talk to each other
why are they so quiet right now
oregonians might well wonder
that these threat actors are doing their
arsons in the tinder
dry woodlands of the state instead of
nearby downtown portland the riots have
stopped
did they go to san francisco or
lancaster pennsylvania to raise hell
did they stop because of the smoky skies
and air quality numbers that are off the
charts
it seems unlikely that a group that
spawned a murderer
multiple arsonists and police assaulters
would be dissuaded by smoky quality air
is it because the media are busy
covering the wildfires and there's
nothing in rioting for the terrorists
or is it because of something else the
riots are over for now
why actually i actually have a very very
simple answer
for first many of the fires
there's a ton of fires many of them were
was arson not the bigger ones but people
have been arrested for
arson they're not black lives matter but
let's go back in time
gdc statement on recent visits to
defendants by the fbi september 4th
2020 we have confirmed reports of the
federal bureau of investigation visiting
people's homes in the last week or so
the result of some of these visits is
that people with state charges
whether they have been no complaint or
not are being arrested by the fbi
for federal charges of a similar nature
below
are some of the steps to take uh some of
the steps to dealing
with an fbi visit now i gotta admit
that's really good advice
they give like you know don't talk to
the police ask for a lawyer don't lie
it's all very basic stuff they say if
you were arrested on state charges
interfering with peace officer unlawful
direct laser anything like this
you may want to take some preventative
measures in case you are visited and or
arrested by federal law enforcement
some steps to take are below and i don't
care about that part
and let's go back in time a little bit
further september 1st
deputized troopers may snarl maltco's
protest prosecution plans
move seemingly overrides multnomah
county's district attorney's limited
prosecution approach mike drop there it
is trump solved the problem
that's why the riots have stopped and
all it could be a combination
so trump goes in deputizes the cops they
send it off to the feds the feds start
busting the figureheads or the real
dangerous people and then the rest of
them are like
let's get out of town because the feds
are coming so they scramble to the
to the woods and start lighting fire no
no i don't think that
i think when the when the key organizers
got got snatched up by the feds
because the the was it portland what is
it what what do they call themselves
the general defense committee they said
the feds are coming door-to-door and
you're getting federal charges similar
to your state charges
they grab the organizers organizers are
gone
now the crazy people who were preyed
upon by antifa
to be used as useful idiots to throw
explosives like that one dude
you remember that guy with the shield
and he was guarding naked athena or
whatever her name was
there was that nude woman and this young
guy was like shielding her
another video came out where someone
hands him an explosive and then he
throws it at the building it goes off he
got charged for it
they don't know who gave it to him he
said some guy gave it to him told him it
was like a spinner he'll go
and fly in the air nope it was a bomb
that guy got in trouble
the the dude who gave him the bomb i can
only imagine must have gotten arrested
or
once the fed started going in and
arresting his people at their homes
the other organizer said the jig is up
and they bolted
and they're gone that leaves all of
these deranged and
unwell people scattered many of the
actual far leftists probably started
preparing for the siege on the white
house on september 17th
many uh many of them probably got scared
stay home lock their door and they're or
they're hiding at their friend's house
many of them are in jail right now being
held by feds and probably will never be
released
and then all of the crazy people who
were wandering around bored and
screaming
because they're literally unwell
wandered off and started starting fires
that makes a lot of sense that's my
theory um i
i look i think that would require
looking at some of these crazies who
have started fires
and seeing if they were at any of these
exactly
it's an it's a safe assumption with a
lot of moving parts
but you know it may not be the peak
crazies the fires might be unrelated
but i think that's definitely the first
part of what you said is extremely
accurate there are arsonists starting
fires
100 percent and and one of them was a
black lives matter leftist now
we should be able to easily prove
whether or not many of these other
people
were at some of these protests but i
guess if they weren't arrested
we wouldn't know but what happens when
you have people who are throwing fire
bombs
at seattle and portland police
departments and now the organizers are
gone
no one's giving them orders and telling
them what to do right they go start fire
somewhere else
yeah i mean some these people were
starting fires
all over the place at the portland
police this is the best theory i can
i can come up with so the riot stopped
and it's very simple
donald trump stopped them you know it
was it was a team effort but yeah he was
leading the team
well i'll put it this way the buck stops
with him
he said we're going to deal with this he
pointed he's got his appointees
through the dhs and other organizations
and they took action
and they were smart and they did it
right we'll see what comes up
we'll see what happens tomorrow night
tomorrow night's the white house siege
oh wow it's the the non-violent seat
white house have they deputized any
other cities cops
uh not that i know that is such a cool
idea i mean it's kind of worrying
so so we're uh well the the feds are
supposed to operate within federal
jurisdiction
they're supposed to like the the fbi
deals with
specific crimes pertaining to you know
interstate commerce kind of things or
like a murderer crossing state lines
many of these people aren't from
portland so the fbi would have
jurisdiction
but now because localities are not
actually dealing with these criminals
the feds are asserting some kind of
warped jurisdiction
to put an end to it i don't like it i
don't like it because
well i do like that they're ending the
riots i do think that is it i think
trump was like
how can we do this without going in and
they said we can deputize the state
police
the dhs was like get it done and i'm
sure trump knew i'd be willing to bet he
did it's a brilliant idea i'm not saying
it was his idea
but i'm sure they were like look we can
do this there may be a legal challenge
but who wants to be the person right now
to sue the feds on behalf of
antifa the democrats have defended
antifa
to an absurd degree but right now they
know it's a vulnerability
so they can't be seen as being
sympathetic and protecting protecting
them right now
i'm the cat wants bucko i see i got
buckle a bowl of water because he keeps
drinking my water but now he wants what
i want he doesn't want the bowl
he's not satisfied now he's taking yours
huh oh you can have it
so anyway come here there you go man you
cut what did you call the other day
cutting the head off the snake
yeah yeah and slice it off it doesn't
always work
because sometimes if it's the system
that's the problem cutting the head off
it'll just grow a new head
yeah it looks like it was top down
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you